ah  i've just had the most bizarre thing  happen to me  okay so i decided i wanted some tea  today and i've got a bunch of old teas  that i haven't gotten to and  specifically i had stuff from this  company zesty this i had leftover from a  promotion i actually ran for them i am  not going to recommend them they didn't  pay me uh also the tea is not very good  but anyway  so i opened up this packet because earl  grey is one of my favorite teas now  unfortunately it didn't occur to me to  record it at the time so i don't know if  anyone's gonna believe me but when i did  open it what was inside  wasn't t  it was this  and and  that  [Music]  the fact that it has that message with  it  i don't know if this was accidental this  seems like somebody's idea of a joke but  what hell  [Music]